[Música]
Brasil acaba de vivir el momento más
decisivo de su historia democrática las
elecciones presidenciales celebradas en
octubre demostraron que Brasil está
dividido en dos Los Seguidores del
presidente Jair bolsonaro y todos los
que están en su contra al frente de esto
se situó Lula da Silva presidente
brasileño a principios de siglo muchos
lo consideraban como el único capaz de
derrotar a bolsonaro y Sí tenían toda la
razón en su discurso de la Victoria Lula
Se comprometió a superar la división del
país en dos bandos y ser el presidente
de todos los brasileños a partir de
primero de
enerobo gobernar para tu fe tu ciclismo
y brasileros y brasileros y no va apenas
para aquellos que votar en mí no es
Brasil
[Música]
vivía en un país divido en permanente y
Estado de guerra este país de Unión este
pueblo desde luego el resultado
electoral fue terriblemente apretado
50,9% Lula
49,1 bolsonaro que haya sido tan
ajustado y que él todavía presidente
consiguiera un resultado mucho mejor que
el esperado en las encuestas hace que
nos hagamos muchas preguntas Cuáles han
sido los principales logros de bolsonaro
en estos cuatro años qué errores han
provocado su derrota Cuáles serán los
principales retos para la Silva en su
nueva etapa presidencial hoy en
visualpolitik vamos a dar respuesta a
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la comunidad de bolsonaro
en la década de los 90 Brasil estaba
anclado en el pasado su industria estaba
protegida por aranceles y existían
prohibiciones a la importación de muchos
productos además el país afrontaba una
acelerada desindustrialización qué es lo
que pasa cuando tus industrias no son
competitivas y eso no es todo para colmo
de males acumulaba cuatro décadas de
alta inflación para acabar con esta
situación hace 30 años el gobierno de
itamar Franco puso en marcha el plan
real un plan que más tarde desarrolló el
gobierno de Fernando Enrique Cardozo y
que supuso cambiar de moneda y aplicar
una reforma fiscal el plan real tuvo
éxito y Brasil se transformó en una de
las economías emergentes más destacadas
la pobreza comenzó a disminuir y la
desigualdad de ingresos se redujo luego
Lula da Silva disfrutó de unos años de
abundancia económica gracias al auge de
las materias primas en los mercados
internacionales de esta forma Brasil se
convirtió en 2010 en
Economía del mundo prácticamente
empatada con la sexta como podéis ver
aquí sin embargo amigos desde entonces
ha caído al duodécimo lugar de este
ranking
cuando la Bonanza petrolera llegó a su
fin las cosas empezaron a venirse abajo
además el gobierno de Dilma Rousseff fue
letal para la economía brasileña y esta
entró en una profunda recesión incluso
la mayor empresa del país el gigante
petrolero Estatal petrobras estuvo
contra las cuerdas y cerca de quebrar el
descontento de la gente impulsó a una de
las figuras políticas más polémicas de
los últimos años Estamos hablando por
supuesto de Yahir bolsonaro su discurso
populista cautivó a millones de
brasileños cansados de los abundantes
escándalos de corrupción que azotaban al
partido de los trabajadores después de
16 años de gobierno ahora bien uno de
los mayores aciertos del presidente
bolsonaro fue incorporar a Paulo Guedes
como una especie de súper ministro para
asuntos económicos
[Música]
Paulo bebé Es doctor en economía por la
universidad de Chicago institución de
referencia para el liberalismo económico
desde que se convirtió en ministro
impulsó una agenda centrada en promover
las privatizaciones simplificar las
regulaciones laborales y reducir la
burocracia una Misión Imposible de
partida ya que según datos del Banco
Mundial Brasil tiene una de las
legislaciones tributarias más complejas
e ineficientes del mundo concretamente
se sitúa en el puesto 184 del ranking
del Banco Mundial que mide a 190
sistemas tributarios
[Música]
la reforma laboral impulsada por el
tándem bolsonaro Guedes ha tenido buenos
resultados la tasa de desempleo de
Brasil alcanzaba el 12% cuando ambos
alcanzaron el poder actualmente y a
pesar del coronavirus ésta se ha
reducido por debajo del 9%. la cifra más
baja desde el 2015 otra de las cartas
jugadas por Guedes fue la de apostar por
las privatizaciones para disminuir la
deuda pública
para convencer a los brasileños
bolsonaro lo ha tenido fácil pero claro
tampoco es que fuera complicado mejorar
la gestión económica de sus predeces
económicos
ahora bien este deseo de reducir el
tamaño de la maquinaria Estatal tropezó
con la realidad cierto es que llevó a
cabo la mayor privatización en dos
décadas Pero al final no se atrevió con
la petrolera petrobras Así que
básicamente todo se limitó a una
privatización parcial de electrobras la
empresa Estatal encargada de la
generación de electricidad en el país
una privatización que atrajo la
inversión del fondo soberano de Singapur
y del fondo de pensiones canadiense
también permitió inversión privada en
materia de agua y alcantarillado pero
sea como sea lo importante es que por
unas cosas y otras los resultados
llegaron
la mejor noticia para Brasil Es que
después de una década nodina en materia
de crecimiento económico el país volvió
a cosechar unas cifras razonablemente
buenas al menos teniendo en cuenta que
hablamos de Brasil una economía
terriblemente burocrática y hostil para
los negocios incluso para los cánones de
latinoamérica Pues bien la pandemia el
astró a Brasil un 4% en 2020 pero en
2021 cosechó un alza del pib del 4,6%. y
en 2022 en el momento de las elecciones
el crecimiento interanual seguía estando
por encima del 3 Estos buenos datos y un
discurso tremendamente polarizado
ayudaron a conformar alrededor del
presidente una comunidad de Auténticos
fanáticos el bolsonarismo
sin embargo un momento amigos porque no
es oro todo lo que reluce los números sí
son razonablemente buenos pero lo cierto
Es que la economía ha crecido Gracias en
gran medida a las políticas de estímulo
del gobierno
[Música]
a la vista de las encuestas bolsonaro
apartó la teoría económica y sacó toda
su artillería para lograr la remontada
aprobó un programa de ayuda con
impuestos más bajos a los combustibles
la electricidad el gas y el transporte
público también apostó por mejorar las
prestaciones sociales la excusa pues
como os podéis imaginar la inflación el
motivo como bien suponéis pues dar un
regalito a los votantes no olvidéis que
para los políticos los brasileños pobres
solamente tienen una cosa que tiene
tanto valor como el de los ricos su voto
Así que para lograr este objetivo
bolsonaros se lanzó a prorrogar e
incluso ampliar medidas sociales que
puso en con motivo de la pandemia
auxilio Brasil de 400 a 600 reales sin
duda fue su medida estrella estamos
hablando de que esta subida del 50%
llevó a auxilio Brasil a unos 110 euros
mensuales
[Música]
además después de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones Se comprometió a
prorrogar esta ayuda durante 2023 la
factura de todo esto no es ninguna broma
ahora mismo auxilio Brasil lo están
recibiendo 21 millones de familias
brasileñas Así que Real arriba real
abajo
comprometido ayudas por valor de 50.000
millones de euros incluyendo nuevos
programas de condonación de deuda y
líneas de crédito sin embargo amigos
todo esto no Fue suficiente para
bolsonaro Tenía muchos errores que
enmendar y la campaña electoral contra
Lula fue como juntar a hinchas del
palmeiras con los del corinthias atentos
[Música]
las dos Torres
la gestión de bolsonaroa ha tenido
sombras importantes negar la importancia
del cobi 19 convirtió a Brasil en el
segundo país del mundo con más muertes
por coronavirus con casi 700.000
fallecidos restar importancia al repunte
de la tala del Amazonas tampoco Parece
ser la mejor carta de presentación en
una escena internacional dominada por
las preocupaciones ambientales y
defender un concepto anticuado del papel
de la mujer en las sociedades modernas
es un obstáculo para que buena parte del
electorado que vote aún así estuvo a
punto de ganar la reelección en un
enfrentamiento entre las dos figuras más
importantes de la política brasileña en
lo que llevamos de siglo porque Lula
también genera rechazo
[Música]
el expresidente Lula da Silva fue
encarcelado tras ser acusado por
corrupción dentro del Gran escándalo
lavallato el cual se produjo alrededor
de la petrolera estatal petrobras pasó
19 meses en prisión antes de ser
liberado por el tribunal supremo que
anuló todas las sentencias contralula al
entender que este asunto escapaba de la
jurisdicción del juez que le había
condenado En otras palabras Lula fue
liberado por un defecto técnico en el
proceso judicial al que fue sometido no
porque el supremo le considerara
Inocente de las acusaciones en su contra
algo por lo que nunca será juzgado
porque los hechos ya están prescritos
[Música]
a favor de Lula ha jugado el recuerdo
entre los votantes durante su
presidencia mejoró considerablemente la
calidad de vida de millones de
brasileños y tenéis que pensar que por
mucho Manny que bolsonaro soltara justo
antes de las elecciones los que reciben
las ayudas son los mismos que están
enfadados por la subida de la inflación
en cualquier caso como os podéis
imaginar hablamos de dos políticos que
no dejan indiferente a nadie y eso se ha
notado en la campaña electoral donde se
han sobrepasado todos los límites ahora
bien si bolsonaro tiene fama de faltar
al respecto a sus rivales políticos no
os penséis que Lula se ha quedado atrás
Brasil juez prohíbe asociar a bolsonarok
con canibalismo en campaña electoral la
campaña electoral ha sido más sucia que
los marcajes a Neymar y es una pena
porque se necesitaban propuestas para
reactivar la economía brasileña el país
ha perdido el rumbo y solo lo sostiene
el auge de su sector agroindustrial
gracias al apetito voraz de China por la
soja y el resto de productos que ofrece
el campo brasileño Esta es una historia
de éxito Ya que Brasil se ha convertido
en el tercer mayor exportador mundial de
productos agrícolas detrás de Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea Pero esto no
basta para el gigante de Sudamérica el
declive de su industria
tiene una tendencia iniciada hace
décadas Mirad la evolución
[Música]
Más allá del sector petrolero y la
agroindustria que ya supone el 28% del
pib el resto del sector Industrial va de
mal en peor El problema es que la
economía brasileña no está generando
empleos bien remunerados como los
perdidos en la industria y después de
una campaña sin propuestas parece que
estas cuestiones no importan a ningún
político y a sus votantes entre los que
tienen mucha incidencia las masas
fanatizadas cuyo único objetivo es
derrotar a sus oponentes Ahí es donde
encajará que haya seguidores de
bolsonarov rogando al ejército que de un
golpe de estado contra Lula parecen
estar dispuestos a todo aunque no a
tanto como algunos quieren hacernos
querer Los partidarios de bolsonaro
utilizan sus móviles para pedir un golpe
extraterrestre algunos medios de
comunicación prestigiosos han caído en
la tentación de dar verosimilitud a esta
noticia con tal de ridiculizar a los
seguidores de bolsonaro millones de
brasileños estarían encantados de que
ete el tobillo a Neymar como si fuera el
dedo Elliot pero amigos Como tantas
veces ocurre la realidad es mucho menos
interesante que la noticia prensa
difundió sobre manifestantes en Porto
alegre Aunque ojo que tampoco hablamos
de poca cosa
[Música]
esas linternas de móviles dirigidas
hacia el cielo son una manifestación más
de ciudadanos brasileños para pedir de
nuevo un golpe de estado a las fuerzas
armadas pero no a los alienígenas todo
para lucir un
sosfa que pudiera captar un dron desde
el cielo pero no El Halcón milenario a
pesar de todo esto parece que bolsonarok
ha aceptado La derrota y no se va a
marcar un Capitolio al estilo Trump la
mala noticia para Lula es que aún así
dirigir Brasil le resultará mucho más
difícil que la última vez que estuvo en
el cargo el país está más dividido que
entonces y sus finanzas públicas están
en peor estado sin embargo es el momento
de que Brasil afronte los cambios
estructurales y avance hacia un modelo
productivo que siente las bases del
crecimiento económico en el largo plazo
Cuáles eran los principales retos de
Lula ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el retorno de Lula
Lula da Silva quiere volver a poner al
estado en el centro de la economía
brasileña para ello planea utilizar el
gasto público para estimular el
crecimiento especialmente en el
desarrollo de infraestructuras a
imitación del build Back better del
presidente estadounidense biden también
quiere ampliar los planes sociales como
el programa bolsa familia sin embargo
amigos para ello tiene que sortear un
importante obstáculo el tope de gasto
público que introdujo hace 6 años el
presidente temer para frenar la crisis
que vivía Entonces el país esto exige
una enmienda constitucional que según
algunos expertos debe ser aprobada por
el congreso antes del 10 de diciembre de
momento Lula ya ha indicado Cuánta pasta
necesita para hacer realidad sus planes
el equipo de Lula Busca exhibir 32.400
millones de dólares del tope de gasto y
ahora sé que muchos estaréis pensando ya
estamos se van a gastar lo que no tienen
sí es verdad pero bolsonaro fue el
primero que se saltó el tope de gasto
primero cuenta de la pandemia pero luego
ya pensando directamente en Cómo ganar
las elecciones la cuestión ahora es como
planea Lula pagar el gasto extra que
propone esos 32 mil millones de dólares
[Música]
Lula habla de políticas que impulsan el
mercado interno para aumentar la
producción y el consumo para conseguirlo
habla de Elevar los programas sociales
la inversión pública y Apoyar el
desarrollo de infraestructura sostiene
que generando unos ingresos más altos
aumentará la recaudación de impuestos
Pero qué queréis que os diga es el
milagro de los panes y los peces en su
versión brasileira la subida de la
recaudación no será suficiente y todo
indica que tirará de deuda pública El
problema es que las finanzas de Brasil
no están igual que cuando Lula dejó la
presidencia Lula no tendrá mucho margen
de actuación el 80% del presupuesto se
va en sueldos de los empleados y
pensiones cuando en la mayoría de países
estas partidas no llegan al 60%. el
gasto público se acerca al 40% del pib
una proporción similar a la de muchos
países ricos pero la calidad de los
servicios que ofrecen a sus ciudadanos
está a años luz de lo que reciben los
brasileños el país necesita muchas
reformas y la primera de la lista es una
reforma fiscal en este aspecto la
administración de bolsonarok fracasó en
el intento ahora es el turno de Lula que
quiere enfocarse en combatir la
desigualdad y mejorar la redistribución
de ingresos todo un reto para Lula que
por fortuna lo tendrá más fácil en otras
materias
[Música]
Lula da Silva va a aprovecharse del
legado del tándem bolsonarogueres a
pesar de que su partido criticó
duramente la reforma laboral en la
campaña electoral no se ha hablado de
derogarla sino de modificarla con
pequeños retoques Lula también criticó
las privatizaciones pero volver a
nacionalizar electrobras tendría un
coste político muy superior a los
millones de dólares que necesitaría
supondría crear inseguridad jurídica
para las inversiones en Brasil algo que
perjudicaría a otros proyectos
gubernamentales como las asociaciones
público privadas para el desarrollo de
infraestructuras
a pesar de su discurso de izquierdas
Lula ha sabido moverse hacia el centro
tal y como demuestra que como
vicepresidente haya elegido a giraldo
admink antiguo líder del centro derecha
además no tiene mayoría parlamentaria Y
eso complicará mucho cualquier cambio
radical por eso todo apunta a que Lula
se va a centrar en mejorar los planes
sociales y sobre todo a sacar adelante
una agenda verde que por ejemplo
reactive el pacto amazónico para
proteger la selva tropical a eso y a
desarrollar una agenda exterior mucho
más activa en la región Lula ha dicho
por activa y por pasiva que la
integración regional será una de sus
grandes obsesiones
pero sea como sea quizá realmente el
principal desafío del nuevo gobierno
brasileño será explicar cómo pagará sus
grandes promesas de gasto seguramente
tenga que sustituir el tope de gasto por
otro mecanismo más flexible pero capaz
de mantener la confianza de los en la
sostenibilidad de la deuda pública Claro
que con un congreso en contra eso no
parece una tarea nada sencilla En todo
caso en esto tendrá mucho que decir la
persona que Lula elija como ministro de
economía Parece que ya tiene nombre y
apellidos Lula se inclinado por el ex
alcaldía para impulsar la economía de
Brasil abad es una opción de la
izquierda moderada como alcalde de Sao
Paulo entre 2013 y 2016 redujo el
déficit presupuestario y aseguró para la
ciudad una calificación crediticia de
grado de inversión no se deja llevar por
políticas populistas y eso en Brasil es
una buena noticia pero ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros creéis que un
presidente como Lula da Silva es lo que
necesita Brasil o pensáis que bolsonaro
se había ganado tener un segundo mandato
para desarrollar al completo sus
políticas puedes dejarnos vuestra
respuesta abajo en los comentarios como
siempre si te ha resultado interesante
Este vídeo Dale al botón de like y no
olvides suscribirte a visualpolitik si
aún no lo has hecho un y hasta la
próxima
[Música]